>> Tucker: MAGNANIMOUS, IF A
LITTLE WRY.
MEMBERS OF THE MIGRANT CARAVAN
ARE NON-AMERICAN, THEY ARE NOT
EVEN IN THE UNITED STATES YET.
THAT MAKES NO DIFFERENCE TO THE
LEFT.
TWO PEOPLE IN THE WORLD, CURRENT
AMERICAN CITIZENS AND AMERICAN
CITIZENS RECENTLY HAVEN'T SHOWN
UP YET.
IF YOU DON'T WANT THEM HERE
IMMEDIATELY, THEN YOU ARE A
MONSTER.
WATCH.
>> THE PRESIDENT OF THE
UNITED STATES HAS DECIDED THAT A
COUPLE THOUSAND SCARED, SICK
PEOPLE FLEEING VIOLENCE ARE A
BIGGER THREAT TO THE
UNITED STATES THEN I SAYS.
>> I SPENT DAYS WITH THE CARAVAN
AND I DIDN'T SEE CRIMINALS, OR,
OR TERRORISTS.
>> HE FEEDS OFF OF THIS VIOLENCE
AND HIS SUPPORTERS BACK HIM ON
IT BECAUSE THEY DIDN'T GET THE
WALL SO THEY MIGHT BE ABLE TO
STOP AN IMAGINARY CARAVAN.
>> Tucker: PEOPLE HAVE GONE SO
MUCH DUMBER IN THE LAST FEW
YEARS IT'S UNBELIEVABLE.
IT SHOULDN'T SURPRISE US IN THE
FACE OF PROGRAMMING LIKE THAT, A
DOZEN HONDURAN MIGRANTS HAVE
SUED THE ADMINISTRATION FOR
SUPPOSEDLY VIOLATING THEIR
CONSTITUTIONAL RIGHT, EVEN THE
ONES THEY HAVE NOT YET REACHED
THE BORDER YET, AND OF COURSE IN
THE BORDER YET, AND OF COURSE IA
THE BORDER YET, AND OF COURSE IE
THE BORDER YET, AND OF COURSE IN
THE BORDER YET, AND OF COURSE IT
THE BORDER YET, AND OF COURSE IA
THE BORDER YET, AND OF COURSE IE
THE BORDER YET, AND OF COURSE II
THE BORDER YET, AND OF COURSE IA
THE BORDER YET, AND OF COURSE IN
CITIZENS.
MIKE, THANK YOU FOR COMING ON
APPEAR TO SPEAK I THINK YOU FOR
HAVING MADE.
>> Tucker: OF COURSE.
A SINCERE QUESTION, I REALLY AM
GLAD THAT YOU ARE HERE.
IT'S HARD TO SEE WITH THE
STANDING IS HERE.
THESE ARE PEOPLE WHO ARE NOT
AMERICAN CITIZENS, NOT ON
AMERICAN SOIL, AND SOME OF THEM
HAVE DECLARED INTENT TO VIOLATE
AMERICAN LAW.
HOW WOULD THE CONSTITUTION
RIGHTS OF THE COUNTRY THEY ARE
NOT A PART OF BEING VIOLATED
EXACTLY?
>> THE MAIN PLAINTIFF IN THIS
LAWSUIT, EACH OF THE INDIVIDUALS
IN THE CLASS ARE INDIVIDUALS WHO
WANT TO SEEK ASYLUM AND DO SO
LEGALLY.
THAT'S AN IMPORTANT PART OF THIS
CONVERSATION.
BUT TUCKER, IT'S A GOOD
QUESTION.
WE HAVE AN IMMIGRATION LAW, IT'S
A SERIES OF IMMIGRATION LAWS,
AND ONE OF THOSE ELEMENTS IS
ASYLUM.
THOSE LAWS ARE SPECIFIC TO THE
INDIVIDUALS IN THIS CARAVAN WHO
ARE COMING TO CLAIM ASYLUM.
THAT ALONE MAY NOT BE ENOUGH BUT
THE PRESIDENT OF THE
UNITED STATES HAS TAKEN TO
MAKING THIS CARAVAN A SYMBOL OF
AN INVASION OF OUR COUNTRY, AND
HE HAS TAKEN A GREAT DEAL OF
TIME TO DEFAME THE INDIVIDUALS
WHO ARE TRAVELING, FLINGING
BLOODSHED IN THEIR HOME COUNTRY,
TRYING TO FIND A PLACE WHERE
THEY CAN LIVE AND SUPPORT
THEIR FAMILIES.
>> Tucker: I GET IT, I
UNDERSTAND YOU DON'T LIKE THAT
AND YOU ARE ON THEIR SITE, YOU
DON'T LIKE TRUMP, FINE.
BUT HOW DOES THAT MEAN THAT THEY
HAVE A CONSTITUTIONAL RIGHT THAT
IS BEING VIOLATED?
WHERE IS THAT RIGHT?
WHERE IN THE CONSTITUTION DOES
IT RESIDE?
AS A NORMAL AMERICAN, AND
CONFUSED.
CAN YOU HELP ME?
>> ABSOLUTELY.
IT'S A RIGHT TO DUE PROCESS.
THESE INDIVIDUALS ARE COMING TO
THE COUNTRY.
THEY HAVE IN ONE WAY OR ANOTHER
STATED THEIR INTENT TO COME TO
THE COUNTRY, AND THE CHIEF
EXECUTIVE OF THIS COUNTRY HAS
TAKEN AIM AND ATTACKED THEM.
WHAT I'M SAYING IS THERE
STANDING IS VERY SIMPLE, THEY
ARE ASYLUM-SEEKERS, THEY WANT
CLARIFICATION.
I THINK WE SHOULD RESPECT THESE
MIGRANTS.
>> Tucker: HOLD ON PEER TO
STOP.
THIS IS A LEGAL QUESTION.
I GET IT.
YOU ARE ON THE SIDE OF THE
MIGRANTS.
THAT'S YOU ARE RIGHT.
I JUST WANT TO KNOW WHERE MY
RESPONSIBILITY BEGINS AS AN
AMERICAN CITIZEN.
YOU ARE SAYING THEY HAVE A
CONSTITUTIONAL RIGHT TO DUE
PROCESS BUT THEY ARE NOT
AMERICANS AND THEY ARE NOT ON
U.S. SOIL, THEY ARE HUNDREDS OF
MILES FROM THE UNITED STATES.
THEY'RE NOT HERE, SO IN WHAT
SENSE ARE THEY COVERED BY OUR
DUE PROCESS PROTECTION?
THIS IS INSANE AND YOU KNOW IT'S
INSANE.
I JUST WANT YOU TO ADMIT THAT
IT'S INSANE.
>> IT'S NOT INSANE, TUCKER.
THEY ARE CLAIMING RIGHTS UNDER
OUR CONSTITUTIONAL STATUTE THAT
AFFORDS THEM DUE PROCESS RIGHTS
UNDER THAT LAW.
THEY HAVE DUE PROCESS UNDER THE
LAW.
THIS IS A LAW THAT IS
SPECIFICALLY DIRECTED TO THEM
HERE TO SO OF COURSE THEY HAVE
DUE PROCESS.
>> Tucker: LET ME CORRECT YOU.
THEY DO NOT POSSESS THOSE RIGHTS
IF THEY ARE IN ANOTHER COUNTRY
AND NOT U.S. CITIZENS.
IF THEY POSSESS THOSE RIGHTS,
THEN, I DON'T KNOW, THE ENTIRE
COUNTRY OF NIGERIA -- PICK A
COUNTRY THAT IS POOR THAN THE
UNITED STATES.
THEY SAY WE WANT TO COME,
PRESIDENT SAYS YOU CAN'T COME
AND ALL OF A SUDDEN EIGHT AND
HALF MILLION PEOPLE SAY THEIR
RIGHTS ARE BEING VIOLATED --
>> WITH ALL DUE RESPECT, THAT'S
NOT WHAT WE ARE TALKING ABOUT.
WE'RE TALKING ABOUT INDIVIDUAL
MIGRANTS COMING TOGETHER ON
THEIR WAY TO THE BORDER TO
EXERCISE THEIR RIGHTS UNDER U.S.
LAW UNDER DUE PROCESS --
>> Tucker: HOLD ON.
BECAUSE IT'S OF YOU?
WHAT'S THE PRINCIPAL IF YOU ARE
A FOREIGNER RESIDING IN A
FOREIGN COUNTRY -- I DON'T KNOW
IF THEY ARE EN ROUTE OR NOT.
>> IF THE ENTIRE NATION OF
NIGERIA WERE EN ROUTE TO THE
UNITED STATES, PERHAPS IT WOULD
BE APPLES TO APPLES.
BUT THAT'S WHAT YOU SAID.
IMMIGRANTS COMING TO THIS
COUNTRY TO SEEK ASYLUM HERE
>> Tucker: FIRST OF ALL, YOU
DON'T KNOW THAT.
YOU DON'T KNOW WHAT THEIR INTENT
IS.
ACTUALLY, YOU DON'T.
THEY ARE HUNDREDS OF MILES AWAY,
AND ASYLUM CLAIMS HAVE TO BE
MADE ON U.S. SOIL.
EITHER AT AN EMBASSY, CONSULATE,
OR AT THE BORDER.
THAT'S A LAW, AS SOMEONE WHO
PURPORTEDLY DEFENDS THE LAW, I
KNOW YOU KNOW.
YOU CAN'T ACTUALLY CLAIM THAT
YOU ARE COVERED BY THE U.S.
CONSTITUTION.
YOU ARE NOT ON U.S. SOIL AND YOU
ARE NOT A U.S. CITIZEN.
>> FORTUNATELY.
I HEAR YOUR ARGUMENT, BUT THE
COURTS DON'T AGREE WITH YOU.
THERE IS A COURT CASE IN THE
D.C. CIRCUIT THAT IS IN THE
MATTER OF RL JOHNSON WHERE A
JUDGE SAID THAT THE
ADMINISTRATION CAN'T USE
DETERRENCE TO CURB
ASYLUM-SEEKERS WHO ARE COMING TO
THIS COUNTRY.
I'M AFRAID THAT THIS IS AN AREA
OF LAW THAT HAS ALREADY BEEN
LITIGATED.
>> Tucker: NO, YOU ARE
INCORRECT.
>> NO, I'M NOT.
>> Tucker: THE UNITED STATES
SUPREME COURT HAS NEVER SAID
THAT DUE PROCESS PROTECTION
APPLIES TO NONCITIZENS ON
FOREIGN SOIL.
THAT HAS NEVER HAPPENED.
>> THE DISTRICT OF COLUMBIA
FEDERAL COURT HAS, THAT'S WHERE
THIS CASE IS.
ONE DAY, IT WILL GET TO THE
SUPREME COURT.
>> Tucker: HERE'S WHAT'S
IMPORTANT.
THE REST OF US KNOW -- BY THIS
STANDARD, ANYONE IN ANY COUNTRY
WHO SAYS HE IS ON HIS WAY TO THE
UNITED STATES AND IS WALKING IN
OUR DIRECTION CAN SUE THE
UNITED STATES FOR SAYING WE
DON'T WANT YOU?
YOU REALLY WANT TO SET THAT
PRECEDENT?
>> DO I WANT TO SET THE
IF THE PRESIDENT OF THE
UNITED STATES ENDANGERS ABUSIVE
VIOLENT RHETORIC TOWARD THE
GROUP OF PEOPLE -- WITH ALL DUE
RESPECT.
I LOST YOU BECAUSE I'M CALLING
THE PRESIDENT -- THIS PRESIDENT
IS BEHAVING BADLY AND YOU KNOW
IT.
>> Tucker: YOU DON'T LIKE THE
PRESIDENT, SO WHAT?
>> IT'S NOT A MATTER OF NOT
LIKING THE PRESIDENT.
I DON'T LIKE THE PRESIDENT
THREATENING TO -- DO YOU
HONESTLY BELIEVE -- DO YOU THINK
THAT'S OKAY COSMIC >> Tucker:
I'M NOT GOING TO GIVE YOU MORE
AIR TIME.
DO I THINK IT'S OKAY?